mona bon voir comment se déroule la
manifestation
un bon joueur amira ils sont plusieurs
centaines de manifestants à avoir
répondu à l'appel de différents
collectifs anti fasciste il manifesto de
lutte contre le racisme contre l'extrême
droite contre l'islamophobie entre
autres en tout cas divers thématiques
sont représentés vous pouvez le voir
peut-être juste derrière moi sur les
images d'olivier molinari un cortège
avec plusieurs plusieurs du point
différentes modes différents collectifs
différents syndicats également présents
ici un dispositif policier assez
important et cette manifestation elle a
débuté aux alentours de 14 heures à
partir de château d'eau le cortège s'est
ensuite élancé dans les rues de paris
il se terminera normalement achète les
pour l'instant tout se passe bien
l'ambiance et du tout
bonenfant beaucoup de slogans hostiles
au gouvernement
à la police en tout cas ce rassemblement
et bien il est organisé par différents
collectifs et peut-être que d'autres
rassemblements vous être organisée dans
les semaines à venir
en tout cas nous on puis de pression
sanguine merci à mona pour toutes ces
précisions